Je ne suis PAS un fait raciste, je déteste tous les
gens de la même manière, vous pouvez simplement arrêter de
battre les gens
tirer était sale,
tout comme je peux tirer la saleté,
vous ne pouvez pas simplement entrer dans la maison comme si
vous viviez toujours ici, vous étiez un sale flic
et vous nous avez tous salis par défaut,
avez-vous pensé à la retraite si vous
m'avez forcé à prendre ma retraite ?  J'aurai ma propre
émission sur Fox News dans une semaine tu
seras mon premier invité dis que tu t'amuses les
lois changent les gens changent mais pas la
nouvelle femme est morte rentrez chez vous et faites un sac
sauf ça mais un jury ne vous laissera jamais faire non
l'homme qui tire sur un autre homme est
entièrement entraîneur sur le moment avez-vous
appris qu'avec le premier homme que vous avez tué,
vous me mentez ou vous
retenez c'est ce que je fais la seule
chose qui ne va pas ici, c'est qu'une caméra l'a
surpris en train de faire la police  travail